Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah. Let's begin.
Okay. So before we.
Start this video, two things, one,
for those of you guys who are curious about the selling of Rob core rings,
that was not a one-off, I'm going to sell them again, but I'm going to,
I'm going to do it again.
I'm not going to leave you guys just once to those rings sold out in two hours.
Now I have not found a way on Etsy to show that the rings were sold out, right?
As soon as a single ring type showed up, sold out,
then it was like Etsy automatically delisted it. Right?
So that's why some of you guys went to the store and you didn't see anything
there because they were all sold out. Right?
But in two hours they were all gone.
Those are the guys who did buy Rob four rings.
You should be able to go on to Etsy and you should see the status of your order.
Ah, they should all be on their way.
The only exception is we got an order from a guy in Norway and we had a little
bit of a complication. It was on our end. It was not anything you did wrong. Uh,
but we fixed it and everything's all sorted out. So, uh,
we will order more Rob core rings and we will send out more Rob core rings and I
will place more up for sale.
So keep your ears open and I will let you guys know when you can buy them. So,
uh, anyway.
Onto the video what's going on.
This is Rob and we are picking up with the conclusion of X of sores.
I hope you guys had a great Thanksgiving week. I know I did.
I definitely needed that break. I absolutely needed that break. Uh,
I was going nuts, just,
I think we've been probably doing this nonstop for about two years without
really taking a break. Uh, so I needed one, but, uh,
but we are picking back up with the conclusion of a, of X of sorts, right?
We're wrapping this whole thing up.
And initially I thought about doing each of these individuals separately,
but I think at this point we can just kind of do all the videos together and
just sort of call it a day.
I do want to touch on the hellions because we're going to kind of skip over
this. The hellions was a totally unnecessary story.
I'm not really sure why it was included in this in the first place.
The only real takeaway those of guys who remember the only real thing going on
with the hellions is that their goal was to get into other worlds and steal the
swords of Morocco. So they couldn't even compete in the first place,
which would basically seem to nullify the entire tournament. Now, as we saw,
not all the fights were being done with swords really only those who needed
swords would be disqualified,
but then Saturday and probably would have changed things.
What ended up happening with the hellions, however,
is that it was revealed that sinister simply wanted to steal genes of mutants
that had just had out there.
And once the other hellions found out sinister managed to achieve his goal to a
degree and then came back to, uh,
the Kirkland gate back into the main Marvel universe,
so to speak and then pretty much killed all the hellions.
And that was basically it, right? So there's a little bit going on there,
but not a whole lot, certainly nothing that works. Whereas, you know,
that warrants us covering the entirety of the story.
But what's really important here is we pick up with the next part of the
tournament, which takes place in cable.
And this is done by virtue of cable having to face off against Bay. Now,
of course, Bay is the wife of Doug Ramsey, right? She's the wife of cipher.
And so cable's kind of watching all this on,
or I guess it's really kind of engaging in this,
knowing that he's probably going to have to kill the wife of Doug Ramsey.
And in that moment of hesitation Bay gets the upper hand.
Now here's the big difference because cable says things like, you know,
if I had been who I was before then this probably never would have been a
problem in the first place and true. The, one of the things that was you guys,
weren't really familiar and I've heard people ask this,
why is cable so young Marvel introduced a retcon con basically having cable's
younger self kill his older self and then take his place as kind of like the new
cable.
It was a way for Marvel to kind of reinvigorate the character a little bit.
I kind of feel like it was unnecessary.
The older cable had a lot of great storytelling and going on,
and I think it's situations, you know,
he would have been a lot more interesting,
useful and would have made the stories a lot more interest frigging,
but such as it is, we ended up getting younger cable. Instead.
Now the problem with younger cable is he's not quite battle-hardened yet.
Not in the same way that his older self is. And he's right. When he says,
if this was this older self, he would have killed Bay like that,
but it would have to spend over,
like he would have just killed her in an instant and would have been like, cool,
like we get the point done.
And he would've like watched Doug Ramsey cry and he probably would have
comforted him and said, Hey man, sorry, but like, you know,
the entire kingdom of Coca-Cola and the entire,
like our entire earth is more important than your wife, right?
So would that be the case with Bay getting the upper hand, uh,
with cable kind of hesitating for a moment, they'd basically topples him.
She breaks his arm and then she goes for the killing blow and Doug jumps in and
asked her to stop, right? He says like, stop, like you've basically one, uh,
this was supposed to be finished, right. And Saturday, and had kind of declared.
This was going to be a battle to the death, right.
It was going to be a fight to the actual death itself, but Michigan kind of,
kind of relinquishes here and says, but some deaths are of the spirit, right?
So in the end for the point to a Rocco cacoa is now down,
basically it's 18 to six, right down by 12 points.
This is a pretty huge number to have to catch up. Now, from there,
you end up picking up with cable, contacting Jean Gray and psych hops directly,
which is something that he's not really supposed to be doing, right.
Using his telepathy and managing to reach to them.
But the fact that he was able to do this to essentially use a telepathic powers,
to reach across dimensional barriers and contact gene and a Cyclops,
that's a huge thing, right? This is really more of an act of desperation,
but for people who create like respect threads, right?
Like the power of the telepathy of, of, of, uh, the power of like cables,
telepathy, what like Jean Gray celebrity or something like that.
This is one of those examples that we'll use. Right. They'll just say like,
was able to use this telepathy across dimensional barriers, right.
Or something along those lines. Right.
That's where this kind of stuff comes from. But the reality,
this is cable looks at the situation and says,
it's dire and we're probably going to lose, right? Like we're down 18 to six.
The deck basically seems to be stacked against us. Like she wants us to lose.
I'm not really sure why. I'm not really sure what's going on here.
I'm going to stay here and fight as much as I can,
but like tell Esmee right of the step broker coups,
it kind of girlfriend of cable. Tell her I love her, right? I mean,
that's kind of where this is now Saturday and steps in and cuts off his
connection. And that's when Cyclops and Jean are like, okay,
we need to do something now we'll get back to them here in a second.
What we're going to do here is we're going to focus on Gorgon, right?
He's the next fight. Now Borgen is one of these guys.
And the reason why he wears a bandana around his head is that if he takes it off
and he looks at, you you'll turn to stone,
but he's being made to face off face off against white sword.
But facing off against white sword is not just fighting him.
It's fighting his 100 soldiers. And so he says like,
you'll fight me after you fight all of them. And so he says like,
once you get through all 100 of these guys, then we'll battle.
That's all he says, number one, right. This first guy comes running in,
gets like, gets his head chopped off in an instant. Then it's two and three.
Those guys get taken down. Then it's four, five and six. Right?
Those guys get turned to stone and then manages to make it through and gouge out
the eyes of Gordon. So his primary power is basically gone here.
And so now he's basically just fighting,
using his own prodigious martial arts skill.
But then it's now you have to fight all the rest of the other ones. Right?
You have to fight seemingly all of them.
And so what ends up happening is that Gordon actually takes out something like
13 of, of like the light source champions, which moves the number up. Right?
So it actually gives them a lead, right?
Because each one of these individuals that he kills counts as a point.
So it kind of seems like Saturday is more or less balancing the numbers.
And so now Coca-Cola is ahead 19 to eight.
And that's when the horsemen step in and say invest, right?
Because if he kills all 100 of your soldiers, it's going to move them up.
They're going to be 106 to 18. They're going to crush us. Right?
Like there's not gonna be any chance for us to win.
Like the term will basically be over, right? I mean, there's not enough,
you know, not enough opponents for us to face off, against to finish this right.
To, to come out on top. This will, that's when white sward stepson and says,
okay, fine. Then the battle will be between the two, two of us.
And it's one of these things where Gorgon knows he's not going to win. Right?
Like he knows he cannot come out on top here.
There's no possible way for that to happen. And the white sword says,
I'm going to kill you. And then I will bring you into my,
bring you into my army and the responsible organ organism, not a chance,
whatever happens to me after this, whatever death awaits me,
whatever comes next, this afterlife, it will not be as one of your henchmen.
Right? And that's when, uh, when white Swan is like, okay, fine.
If you don't want to be, then you don't have to be.
But hundreds of sort through his chest and basically killed him.
Now there's two pool things that come out of this.
The first is apocalypse kind of commenting and saying,
this is how a mutant dies. If you're going to die, you die on your own terms.
You die in saying, I'm not going to be a subject to anybody else,
but you die with what you perceive to be your own honor.
The other thing that comes out of this as a Gordon was,
I wouldn't necessarily say an essential member of the X-Men roster,
but somebody who probably could do with a bit of revamping and the reason why is
because Vulcans never really had major roles in Marvel for quite some time.
This is kind of an exciting moment because it could be one of these things where
mobile just never to bring him back, right.
Pitman just kind of writes them out and he's gone or it could be,
they bring him back. It's totally changed because remember he died here.
In other words, which means if they resurrect him,
he'll come back in any number of different versions of himself from across the
multi-verse. We don't know which version it will be. So he could come back with,
with better powers. He could come back weaker.
He could come back as just some old Sage wise, man who never fights.
He could come back in a wide array of different forms,
but Oregon having been destroyed right now, the score is currently even a Rocco.
19 Cracow at 19. And I need you to keep that in mind, hold that in,
in your mind, as long as you can, because this will be.
How important,
because this leads into the final battle between apocalypse and his wife.
Who's donning the helmet of annihilation.
One of the things that happens here is an apocalypse challenges, his wife,
to face him off as herself, right? To basically not use the power of,
of annihilation or any of that stuff to really just kind of husband and wife
dueling each other. But the other thing that comes out of this,
it's really more, uh, with Jean Gray and.
Cyclops that with the messages they receive from cable and the fact that things
seem so dire go to the quiet council, right? And they say like,
we need to go do this.
Like we need to go rescue our son and the quiet castles in a,
in a bit of a predicament, right?
Because the biggest issue they face is that when they ask Cyclops,
what is it you intend to do? Psych Papa's response is twofold. One.
I'm going to assemble a strike team.
This strike team is going to be a smash and grab job, right?
We're just going to break into the other world. We're going to pass in there.
We're going to grab our X-Men and we're going to come back.
We need you to hold the gate open until we do. Now,
the issue with the quiet council is, but what if you die over there, right?
If you die over there, there'd be no way for us to know, right?
Because Saturday Nina's cut off any telepathic communications to that realm.
So it's not like we can maintain a telepathic lifeline and know whether or not
you survive and say, Oh my God, psych cops and Jean, and all the X-Men are dead,
are at close a portal. So they, it, so nobody can get in.
They just kind of have to wait and see.
But if they die over there and there's no way of knowing they died,
they could potentially just be holding the portal open for an invasion that they
didn't know was coming. So they could literally so their own end.
The other part of this is that Jean Gray and psych hops were part of the quiet
council. And so it basically be taking away from, from their number. Now,
anybody who's familiar with governmental positions knows that usually
individuals who hold positions of government are not afforded the opportunity of
putting their life on the line. Leaders don't have that luxury, right?
Because somebody has to govern, it's the responsibility you take.
And so what this means is that while sock hops and Jean are simply just going to
go, right? It's one of these things where it's like,
we're going to find a way to leave.
So you're going to have to like lock us up or something that in turn the quiet
counsel, now that they're met with the, the idea that, uh,
that like Nightcrawler wants to go, their concern is okay,
then what do we do now? Right.
What do we do in this instance where the quiet council could potentially lose
three or four of their number?
Do we simply just hope they come back in one piece?
Do we ensure the governing body can function the way that it's supposed to?
Because river, everybody here has a role to play.
So the government has to continue on. And so in order to,
to basically satisfy this me to answer this question,
a vote is given and the vote is, is given in two forms.
The first vote is if you guys pass through that gate and you die,
and there's no way for us to know that you die and we could be holding the gate
open for, then that means we have to close the gate, right?
We can't take the chance that if you perish there and we don't know that we
allow all the enemies to come flooding in, right?
Any chance that we have of closing the gate will be gone at that point.
And so what they say is Neil, the first vote is Doobie close the gate.
After the forces of the strike team, Jean Gray, sock hops,
after they all pass through the answer is yes. Right? We close the gate.
The second concern is what do we do about you guys leaving the quiet council and
potentially dying.
So do we just kind of hope that you guys make it back in one piece?
Do we put the entire government on hold in order to, you know,
in order to find out whether you made it back,
never knowing how long it could take you to get back that if something went
wrong and you guys were stuck there for decades and decades,
or you guys just grew old there and died because you can never find a way back.
Do we just kind of allow the quiet council to function in its own way without
you guys there? Or do we fill your seats? And when they vote, the answer is,
if you go, you lose your spot, right?
We're going to replace you with somebody else. But at the end of the day,
Jean and Cyclops don't care, their stances. We don't care. Like we are going,
what we're going to go with this, you know, apocalypse is already there, right?
And it may very well be that he might perish that,
that there's individuals who are out there that are supposed to be on the
council that could very well die. And so, because of that, no,
they've already lost so many of their number. They effectively vote.
If Jean grand Cyclops pass through this gate and they take the strike team and
they go to other world for this mission,
then they give up their position on the quiet council and Jean grey.
And cycop say, we're okay with that. And they leave,
but they basically walk away because it's one of these things where they say,
if, if the CRI council is the government of Kakoa,
then the X-Men are its heroes.
And of what use our heroes who refuse to fight my allegiance is to the mutant
population. My allegiance is to the people. And if we,
as the quiet council are going to sit and just rest on our laurels effectively,
you know, and just kind of,
not really do anything in the face of such dire straights,
that of what use are we? Right?
And so Cyclops and Jean basically leave and where you would expect some measure
of condemnation from a quiet council instead, it's really Magneto insight.
And [inaudible] who were just like, that's exactly how we raised you.
That's exactly what you, what we're supposed to do.
And it's one of these things where we can kind of assume a lot of the reasons
why some of these folks don't leave could very well be tied to like Maura
McKendrick.
And the idea that like does this kind of greater game that was established
during the house and powers of X and the sense that like, if they perish,
everything would come to an end,
it really seems to point to the idea that gene grain side cops are not really
that essential to the future survival of the X-Men either.
That, or this is something that has to happen. Right.
But regardless of the situation, they basically pass through.
Brew and they go into, into other world itself.
And so picking back up with apocalypse and his wife.
Things are interesting here. This is kind of cool. It's this really,
really amazing moment where the wife of apocalypse gets the upper hand, right?
Genesis gets the upper hand on him and like destroys a sword.
And says, okay,
like I give you one last kiss and then I will hear your surrender and welcome
you back to your rightful place by my side.
And then she sh like wants you to just raise the sword. She asks like,
will you yield apocalypse? Here's the thing to understand about apocalypse.
Right? Always outnumbered, never.
Outgunned, right? Apocalypse is not a guy.
Who falls easily. Right. This is not a man who yields and that's exactly.
That's exactly what he says, man. Jonathan Hickman, Jonathan, Jonathan,
Jonathan, Jonathan Hickman, man, man. It's it's man.
It's it's it's so it's like, but it's like one of the coolest moments.
Cause apocalypse was like, I will not yield. Not to fear,
not to doubt and not to love where Genesis thought she had the upper hand and
four moves it's bat, bat, bat, and then she's done, right.
That's the end of Genesis. Like literally like just swipes right through.
And that's that, you know, like, like, and it's,
and it's nuts because that's the thing, man, apocalypse man is bad people, man,
man, she's sleeping on a pocket of sun. Like that's exactly what it is.
And that's what makes it so crazy is because with her basically.
Defeated apocalypse is like, I don't want this. Right.
He looks out at Nina and he's like, I don't want this. Right.
I don't want to kill my own wife. I'm not in favor of this. Now keep in mind,
the score is still 19 to 19, whoever this wins.
The contest.
And so with that Saturday seems like I don't really care what it is that you
want. Right? Like the tournament must go on.
You must slay your wife or be slayed by your wife for Victor to be determined
here. But in this moment when apocalypse and Saturnino having this conversation,
then suddenly like Genesis puts on the helmet of annihilation,
completely heals herself. And it's just like, nothing is settled, right?
Like I annihilation and now in total control, your nothing is settled, right?
Like this will go on and we will fight. Now when that happens, right?
Like when she dawns it, helmet of annihilation, she calls in every one,
like literally all the forces of Amref just come pouring into other one at this
point, it's just like men, the hell with the tournament son. Like,
we're just going to do this right now. Like,
that's exactly what this is right now. The, the different little fairy people,
whatever they are, the fish folk of, uh, like the forces of, of,
of Saturday and right here, a little assistance AIDS, whatever they are,
they immediately run and grab like the little, uh, like these, this,
this kind of box right there contains all these little puzzle pieces more or
less. And the idea is that when Saturday and puts this together,
it would have to fit effectively,
give her an answer on what her next move needs to be and what it is a sheet that
she needs to do in this. But without, you know,
beyond Saturday and what's going on right now is all hell is breaking loose sun.
Like all these forces of Amazon are pouring in here and you've got like six
X-Men and captain Britain basically facing off against them,
all doing everything they can now where we're Amith goes for the killing blow
against the apocalypse. And seemingly he's just going to let it happen. Right.
Like out of nowhere, she struck by lightning, right out of nowhere,
she's struck by lightning, inter storm, right. Storms like, okay.
So she's only going to be delayed for so long, right?
Like she's only going to be delayed for so long.
Like we've got our armies routed. We have to get out of here. Right?
Like we have to leave. And the responsible Hotlips is like, not a chance, man.
Like no way. We're like, there's no way I'm leaving my wife behind.
But at this point it's not even the stance of, of apocalypse and what he wants.
It's like, like run, run runaway, live to fight another day. Right?
Like we can get out of here. We can get back to her Koa. Yes. I guess. I mean,
the scores currently tied. We can figure this out later. Right.
But like for right now we need reinforcements or numbers or something.
While that's going on,
Bay actually ends up abandoning the forces of Morocco grabs Doug, uh,
Doug Ramsey and just runs. Right. Just like takes off running. Right.
It's just like, okay. So like she snatches up her husband, right.
Because you know, she's like, Hey, you know,
I need to make a man out of you before, before we're done.
So she snatches him up. They just go running.
And so all the X-Men what's left of these guys are basically just fighting to
the point of exhaustion. They're just fighting like to this moment,
to this point of exhaustion. And there's not a whole lot that they can do here.
It's just like, like at this point you've got what you've got captain Britain,
you've got Wolverine, you've got apocalypse,
you've got storm and you got magic and that's it against this virtually endless
horde of all these guys will then out of nowhere here comes Jubilee, right?
Like you're going to Jubilee coming in with like all these fairy folk. Right.
Because she was just kind of hanging out with him for a little while.
I guess it's by no means like a, like a turn lane. It's not like,
there's like the battle is turned, right. I mean, as Jubilee, great fireworks.
Right? She's like, you know, PDB, BDW PBL WVU.
She creates fireworks where there's really nothing going on there.
But at the very least their numbers are temporarily bolstered and it does give
them a chance to kind of survive experience.
Now what you also end up having is Doug Ramsey talking to Bay and saying,
look like, basically I love you, right? I mean, it's more or less what he said,
right? It's this declaration of love. Like absolutely love you,
but we cannot stay here. Right. We can't just run away from my friends.
We have to go back. We have to help them survive.
Like we have to make sure that they live through all of this. Right.
We have to find a way to end this tournament. I can't just leave them alone.
And so one of the things he kind of asked her, he's like,
you don't have to stay here. Right. You don't have to stay with, with a Rocco.
You can come back when this is all said and done,
you can come back to Coca-Cola and live among us. Right.
You can live at my place, like we're married. Right. So, I mean, you know, it's,
it's, it'll take a little bit of decorating. I mean, it's a bachelor pad. No,
it was a bachelor pad until like a day ago when we got married, you know,
and happened out of nowhere, I wasn't really expecting it,
but you know what I mean, surprise has happened in this game of life.
I don't know what to tell you. So it's, it's, it's kind of a,
it's kind of a cool little thing,
but like basically of course ends up traveling back, you know, an NSO, the,
the forces are Marshall a little bit larger,
but still there's not much they can do here.
The funny thing about that is that when all this begins to happen,
as all this is taking place, you know, annihilation, you know,
basically Genesis, you know, it's more or less possessed by annihilation now.
It's like, it's like, we want, right. Like we basically won here.
This not necessarily formal because I haven't killed apocalypse,
but I'm going to, but I'm going to destroy this guy. We'll then from there,
we switch over to Saturday and a Saturday, Nene is assembling this,
this puzzle piece. That's when she, she begins to realize, Oh my God, like she,
like she has to reassemble the captain Britain court more so than that, this,
this kind of puzzle that seems really existed before, before she ever took over.
Was it, you know, it's a little ambiguous.
It all seems to point to the idea of like the definitive captain Britain and the
definitive captain Britain is Betsy Braddock,
quite like the fates have more or less determined. It's Betsy, Brett. Now,
when I say the fates, I don't mean some individual out there who put this,
you know, box of pieces here and then said, okay, you know,
now Saturday afternoon or surprise,
when you find out who the person is supposed to be, you know,
it's just one of these things where looks like it's out of her control.
That's one of the things about other world is it's very, very ambiguous, right?
There's a lot of talk about the fate sin and how things can unfold and you know,
how it can end and whether or not things would turn out the way that you hoped
it to you. It's one of those things is a little ambiguous,
but the big takeaway from all this is the captain Britain core completely gets
reformed by Saturn, right?
She reformed the entire core and the entire court comes, responded.
They come pouring in, they all come flying in and it's like, okay,
like our numbers are bolstered. Like we have a chance.
The fact that the captain Britain court is reformed is pretty cool. Right?
We haven't seen them since the events of the incursions when they were all
killed by the mapmakers in the beyond hours. Right?
So this is the first time that we're seeing the captain Britain court fully
reassembled now for, for the forces of annihilation, as she continues fighting.
And as a captain Britain Corps comes showing up.
They're not really putting up a huge fight, right?
There's not really a whole lot doing here. Uh,
and they're actually getting taken out quite readily.
But what she says in response to all this is like,
they summon an army summon one of our own, as she talks to like war,
like she's like summon one of our own.
So they summoned all these just helpless looking crews,
all these just terrible looking monsters from the world of like, literally from,
from like annihilation realm, something like all these different,
huge monstrous beasts and things like that. Like, it's getting kind of crazy,
right? It's getting absolutely bonkers.
And it's one of these things where you end up having side pops and Jean who
chime into magic. Now here's the, here's the thing that happens, man.
Here's the thing. Here's the thing that happened, that happens. So she hits up,
here's some psych hops and Jean [inaudible] like,
off and Gina hit up magic and they say, okay, like,
you need to open a portal for us. Right? Like we have our forces here.
You need to open a portal. And they're like, she was like, okay,
like I was wondering how long it would take for you guys to get here. Right.
So slammed her sword into the ground, opens a portal. And when it,
when she does, it brings in the entire sword space station, right.
This whole sword space station, when it opens up, everybody comes pouring out.
Right. So you've got wind pools. You've got dupe, you've got gambit. Right.
You've got, you got all kinds of people here. You've got Quintin choir.
So you got like this huge mish-mash of like all these Omega level mutants and
all that stuff. Like it's,
it's like almost the entire forces of Precoa like everybody who's currently an
X-Men comes pouring out into this thing and all hell breaks,
loose nanometers. [inaudible] John,
John Hickman, man, man, man, man, man,
they were not prepared. The forces of Amith ju just like the, the,
they, it is an absolute massacre, right? Like it's an absolute bloodbath.
They start so many, even more of their monsters. Right?
Like even more of their absolute monsters. They're like,
she's like summing it all summing everything. Right.
Bring everything in here that you possibly can.
So all these monsters start pouring in here. Right?
Like all these things just start jumping in here.
The X-Men are all like fighting for their, like, like fighting for their lives,
man. Like it's, it's, it's, it's absolutely bonkers. And so from there, like,
like you have cable, who's kind of watching all this unfold and he's just like,
he's like, dude, it doesn't look like there's really a way for us to win.
And Saudi Dean's kind of talking to them. And she was like, what card?
Where you dealt. And he was like the fool.
And she's like only a fool would really look at this sword and believe that's
all he's really holding. Now. Remember back when,
when Donovan or I'm sorry with X's sword was going on.
Remember back when they were in the sword space station and the whole sword
space station was taken over by those crazy looking monsters. Right?
Those crazy looking monsters did only desire, death and destruction. Right?
You guys remember that?
And they managed to push them all back through that portal and lock them away in
the realm of death. What is happening is cables just like, Oh my God, right?
Like, I totally forgot about that.
This is why Jonathan Hickman does this stuff because they've got an army of
forces. They're just in the, in the thousands and thousands and thousands.
This seemingly matched the forces of a Rocco at,
or at least that seems to be the case. Quite that like match that huge army,
the forces of EMyth. Like it's just waiting in the wings.
All they have to do is just unleash it. Right. And so like, cables,
like get me to get me to the. Right.
Get me to the sword ship given to that device.
We're all we have to do is unlock. And they're like, okay.
So as soon as they get in there and they literally unlocked that door,
all those forces come pouring in like, hell, right? Like Eliana,
Rasputin makes a portal.
So they all go flying into that portal and they show up into this realm and just
start killing everything they find. Right? I mean, if anything,
it's like Lord of the ranger regiment where like that,
that army of the dead guys, the ghost or whatever it,
but as soon as they show up, like the whole battle just turns. Right.
That's exactly what happens. There's this amazing moment. Right?
We're like one of these, these monster things are like,
we've suffered in a dead realm for far too long, picked its bones,
examine it fully. Now we seek a heartier meal and like an right annihilation,
right? Like this, this chick for the,
the helmet chick with the wife Wilcock lift. She's like,
you want the full measure of a world than come preacher,
taste my metal and feast on Amazon. And like just a night.
This guy. Right. Like,
I love the way that Jonathan Hickman does like these one-liners.
So ridiculously cool. And so like from there,
like where she goes to make this other statement, apocalypse grabs her, right.
Let's like tackles her down to the ground and rips the helmet off her face.
Right? Like rips, rips that the helmet of Amith off the face of Genesis.
And you remember the helmet of EMyth has its own its own mind what it does,
its own thing, you know?
And then anybody who wears the helmet it's possessed by the helmet.
And so apocalypse puts the helmet on. Everybody stops. Right.
Everybody stops and was just like, dude, Holy cow,
this is really going to happen right now.
There's a pocket what's going to put the helmet on and apocalypse grabs it and
sits it on its head. And like, and, and, and literally he's just like,
I am remade. Right. I am apocalypse. You know,
I am totally remade him and annihilation try,
like Emma tries to take over apocalypse, right?
Like an eyelash and tries to take over apocalypse. And like, and,
and initially it seems to be successful,
but then like apocalypse takes over control.
Like he takes over control of the helmet and it's just like, no,
like I am apocalypse.
I'm not some servant to some arbitrary object that exists out there that some
demon entities and possession of, right?
Like when you step into the realm of apocalypses sphere of influence,
you fall to the influence of apocalypse, right.
I will not be controlled by anybody and just totally dominates the helmet now
while all that's happening.
And the way in which we know that everything is going to turn is ISCA turns
against the forces of, of a Rocco.
And that's when they realize we're not going to win. Right. Like.
Literally her power is to always win. So as soon as she turncoats,
then it's like, okay, then we've basically lost here.
And that's what apocalypse steps that Saturday in and says, can you hear me?
And she says, yes, I can hear you and I can see you. And then he says,
then fine, I, as,
as a host of annihilation and the leader of the forces of, of the Iraq army,
I surrender and just.
Gives up and that gives the wind to cacoa right.
Dude. It's amazing. Manager's like, dude, that's so that's such a ridiculous,
equal idea. And this Saturday is like, cool, done. Let's do this. Right.
So she goes flying in with.
Go dragon, right? Who's dragon fire member has the ability to melt realm.
And just like literally punches a hole in this fabric of space,
which rips through all the forces of it.
Of EMyth. Right. And like rip them all through. And even those,
those weird demonic looking force entity guys. Right?
So those are all more or less out of the way, the demand,
the weird guys and the other dimension,
they're all pulled back in the forces of, of AMA.
Kind of waiting to find out what their orders are going to be. Especially like,
like what do we do now?
And so essentially the, the helmet is pulled off of apocalypse Saturday.
Structures it, and turns it into a staff, which is actually really,
really great.
Cool. And then from there, it's kind of like, okay.
So like now that this content.
Is basically done, then I want to show a good faith,
but I want to show a good faith that you guys are not going to wage war against
each other again. And when question is, what's the show of good faith.
She's like, I want a mutant from cacoa to go to a Rocco.
And I want a meeting from a Rocco to go to Coca-Cola.
That's what I, that's what I require. That's what I asked now.
Kilt with apocalypse. Uh, basically he ends up going with the Rocco forces,
right? He ends up joining a Rocco.
Now this is not mean that Marvel is getting rid of a pocket. If anything,
they're probably just kind of keeping him on the back burner for a little while,
because in reality, this whole extra swords event was a story about apocalypse,
but that's basically all this was, it was just a story about apocalypse.
But when the question's asked, who basically speaks for Coca-Cola,
who from Coca-Cola is going to demand somebody from a Rocco come to their,
come to their location. Apocalypse says as the only member,
or really the highest ranking member of the quiet council here,
I will speak for Precoa.
And the person that I choose from a Rocco to come to cacoa is the entire Rocko
nation, the entire Island itself. Right.
I want the Island of a Rocco and that's true. Remember a Rocco is a,
an Island and it was one half of Kakoa when they were Oak Hora. Right.
That's the whole idea. And they were split in the,
in the sense of like all these forces showing up in the first place.
And apocalypse was basically the one that did it.
He's reuniting the Island of cacoa with the Rocco
recreating. Oh, Cora. But he's doing it at the sacrifice of himself.
He is leading with his forces and it's one of these cool things,
because what it does is it transforms the character of apocalypse.
It takes them away from this guy. Who's just like, Oh,
we're just going to the shore stuff.
That's the people who are, you know, the most fit to make sure they're,
they're actually fit, you know,
and just kind of be a Dick from time to time anal and, and, you know, and,
and the transforming from like that guy into,
I am basically sacrificing my place on the quiet council.
So I can be with my wife and my kids. Right.
It makes him a tragic hero. And it's amazing. It's absolutely amazing.
That's why stories like this are so cool because Jonathan Hickman is so good at
changing up the entirety of characters.
And so what you get here is a little bit of an epilogue,
and I'm not going to spoil too much here because I believe this is going to go
into.
What is it? The, the reign of X, N like N L. Okay. I'll, I'll,
I'll throw this out there.
It looks like Jim Jasper's is going to kind of seize control, right?
Like it's going to focus.
On Jim. Jasper's kind of rising to control.
And then who knows what's going to happen. Right. Who hasn't had it yet?
Here's something I want to make clear to you guys. Saturday was bound by magic,
right? She's bound by the limits of magic.
So there's only so much you can do there.
She's bound by like the limits of fate and all that kind of stuff.
When it comes to other world is all kinds of tradition,
fade all pomp and circumstance, all that kind of stuff.
Jim Jasper's is a crazy guy with the ability to manipulate up to, you know,
everything up to and including the most reverse, right.
This guy is just a as on a whole nother level, right?
Like Jim Jasper's is ridiculous. Now, like Jim Jasper's,
if he's anything like the way he was before,
but has more fine tune control over his powers,
then they've probably been expanded. Right. And if they'd been expanded, if Jim,
let me, let me put it this way.
If Jim Jasper's weakness that he has to have a reality to manipulate an order to
be on B, be it as absolute peak. If that weakness is removed,
Jim Jasper's is right up there with like the living tribunal. If it's re if,
if that's removed, I'm not saying it is, but if that's removed,
Jim Jasper's is well beyond the.
Marquis of death and Matthew Malloy and protege and all those guys,
he's right up there with living tribunal.
If not between the living prime Udall and the one above all,
like there's no limit to what he can do. That's a big if,
and we don't even have any idea what they're going to do with this character.
Right? So don't take this as an absolute truth. I'm not saying that it is,
but as kind of bonkers, right. It's kind of crazy because when,
when the dust settles and everything Saturday,
and really kind of retakes her place as the Omni Versal magistrates,
and she got pretty much everything.
She wanted the reformation of the captain Britain core,
the one person she didn't get was Brian Bradick, you know,
she of course wanted him more than anybody else. But in essence,
the entire Omni vessel development court has been restored.
She's back to being the Omni bristle magistrates.
And the captain Britain core has been returned.
That's one of the reasons why I wanted to cover the, uh,
the original Magnum Jasper story, all that stuff is coming back.
What all that stuff is, is basically back to the way it was before.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end. Uh,
I loved XO sorts. I love the Xs swords event. It was so good.
But if you guys are new here to comments, explain it,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the rod poor.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and that we'll catch you all later.
Please.